when we're out and we're drinking at one  point he's like so what's a nice girl  like you doing out with a guy like me oh  God what about yourself and I was like  what the [ __ ] and I was like wait what  what does that mean why is that so funny  who are you because like by all accounts  you made it through my first [ __ ]  like level of judgment I guess where I  was like okay you seem to have a nice  job you look nice you look clean  whatever and then all of a sudden he  busts that out I think he thought that  that was sexy oh God like he was a bad  boy it did not go as he thought it  probably would which would be like me  being like Oh my god oh you're a bad boy  I use that for my stream every time I  get a donation  I actually thought he was like Rico  Suave and that that was again